mon nom est Eve j'étais autrefois bien
reconnu par le fait que je ne porte pas de
chemises avec de grandes fleurs aux
couleurs vives maintenant nous sommes sûrs que c'est avec de petites
fleurs et des couleurs pas si vives alors
peut-être que c'est une meilleure version de moi-même
mais j'ai toujours des chaussettes orange  sur mes pieds
donc ça aide donc une fois que j'étais comme ce
gars j'étais chercheur à l'université
ce qui n'est pas une mauvaise chose
j'étudiais la corrosion locale des
alliages de cuivre pur dans des environnements contenant du chlorure de sodium
c'est très
intéressant n'est-ce pas
apparemment c'est intéressant  pour savoir
comment les déchets nucléaires sont stockés pendant de
nombreuses années et une option pour moi tout en
étant chercheur serait de devenir
ce type, donc rester un chercheur
enquêtant sur des choses intéressantes de
manière plus progressive en améliorant les choses en
comprenant mieux les choses
pour que ma barbe tourne  gris mais je ne suis
plus dans les genoux parce que pendant
mon doctorat j'ai passé un peu plus de temps à
faire d'autres trucs parce que dans le labo
je travaillais c'est un moteur  ering lab et
il y avait beaucoup de questions venant de
parties industrielles des entreprises arrivaient
avec un tuyau qui commençait à fuir il y
a eu l'impulsion blanche il y a quelques années l'
autoroute de 19 poteaux blancs qui sont tombés sur
des échangeurs de chaleur qui ont cessé de fonctionner
et puis les entreprises sont arrivées  au
département et ils ont demandé pourquoi cela se
passait que se passait-il que se passait-il
en fait j'ai passé plus de temps à
enquêter sur ce qui s'est passé là-bas à chaque
fois qu'à enquêter sur mon véritable
sujet de recherche, puis ce que j'ai découvert à ce
moment-là, c'est que beaucoup de choses continuent
à mal tourner  dans l'industrie et moi aussi en
expliquant ce qui se passe Oh, beaucoup de
ces choses pourraient être évitées mais en
regardant mes recherches quotidiennes, je
ne voyais pas comment je pourrais en
faisant ce que je faisais tous les jours à l'époque
changer  comment pourrais-je influencer le fait que je
faisais des progrès progressifs, puis que je
changeais et améliorais les choses, mais
sans
vraiment modifier la façon dont la société
travaillait dans le monde de l'industrie  d donc j'ai décidé non je
veux prendre les choses en main je
veux vraiment changer les choses faire de grosses
vagues alors comment faire de grosses vagues tu
peux te transformer en roue et puis
il y avait une petite voix à l'arrière de
ma tête qui  a dit peut-être que vous devriez créer
une entreprise sur laquelle nous commençons à réfléchir que
c'était en 2008-2009
pour être vraiment actif dans le
tissu industriel dans les environnements industriels, alors
j'ai commencé à regarder les décès d'accord, j'avais
développé une technologie à l'
université et j'avais clairement  un problème
énoncé parce que parce que les choses tournent mal
ces choses coûtent de l'argent vous avez renversé
vos usines qui ont cessé de fonctionner à
cause de crashs à cause de la rupture
de parties de l'usine de sorte qu'il y
avait un problème il y avait une technologie wow
c'est parfait n'est-ce pas euh allons  démarrer une
entreprise ne pourrait pas être si difficile, juste facile
à f technologie vous créez une entreprise vous êtes
assis dans votre bureau vous faites des
publicités c'est ma solution et les
entreprises viendront à vous et par n  o
[ __ ] j'avais tort côté geek de moi un
graphique ce que vous voyez ici est le nombre d'
entreprises dérivées créées à l'
université et au fil des ans et en
fait le moment où j'ai commencé avait
l'idée était 2008-2009 vous en voyez une
ou deux entreprises dérivées ont été créées,
donc à l'époque, tout le
concept de démarrage n'était pas si sexy que ça je n'étais pas
aussi stimulé qu'aujourd'hui aussi ok je
démarre une entreprise nous apportons la technologie et
j'ai commencé à parler à d'autres personnes  mais en
fait, je n'ai trouvé aucune expérience
ou connaissance supplémentaire dans mes relations avec
les personnes que j'avais dans mon environnement direct,
donc aucun membre de la famille qui
ajoute vraiment l'expérience de la
création d'une entreprise, vous avez beaucoup parlé à des
professeurs qui étaient en fait très
compétents mais  mais pas dans le dans l'
entreprise a aussi un peu dans le
désert donc à voir mais j'étais quand même
convaincu d'accord je démarre une entreprise
semble très cool faisons-le ce
sera ma vie je crée une entreprise je serai le
gars avec l'appel de téléphone portable  passer toute la journée à
faire des affaires, vous savez que les revenus sont cool, mais
ensuite j'ai commencé c'était la réalité,
donc dans DQ, c'est la route et les choses tournent
mal parfois et cela m'aurait fait
commencer comme d'accord, c'est peut-être que ce n'est pas
si facile que nous le découvrons alors la prochaine
chose  J'ai fait était
peut-être que je devrais consulter des experts car
oui, un credo que j'essaie de garder à l'esprit est que
vous ne devriez pas répéter les erreurs que d'
autres personnes ont déjà commises avant vous, alors
parlons aux gens, alors j'ai commencé à
consulter des experts de différentes manières et
que faire  ils disent et vous devriez écrire un
plan d'affaires ouais et puis il y a d'
autres experts que vous payez et pour une
somme d'argent ils étendent votre
plan d'affaires de 80 pages à 100 pages
super vous devez protéger votre
technologie obtenir un brevet ouais vous devez
vous améliorer  votre technologie alors oui, la
meilleure façon de commencer quelle est la structure de l'entreprise
, ce sera une
société à responsabilité limitée ou une autre société, donc ils
parlaient tous exactement de pièces structurelles,
etc., etc. et j'écoute
faire mon  J'ai entendu ce que j'ai dit et j'ai
essayé de le mettre en œuvre sur un an et en
fait ce que j'ai remarqué, c'est que
ces conseils n'ont en fait pas progressé
qu'ils ne nous ont pas fait progresser nous étions
très intéressants les conseils des
experts mais ils  n'a pas vraiment aidé
j'aurais dû les jeter là-dedans pourquoi
parce que beaucoup de ces experts
venaient de grandes entreprises bien établies
et de grandes
entreprises établies c'est comme un gros pétrolier
ça va tout seul ça prend beaucoup de
force et beaucoup  de patience pour changer
la trajectoire, nous savons même qu'une grande
entreprise comme un gouvernement peut être le
Belge, elle peut fonctionner pendant plusieurs jours
sans aucun gouvernement, alors en fait,
ces gens savent-ils vraiment ce qu'il
faut pour démarrer quelque chose pour
démarrer quelque chose parce que  c'est un
terrain de jeu différent et il s'est
avéré que DJ, ils ne le font pas en général
parce qu'un live d'une startup est quelque chose de
totalement différent par rapport à la vie
d'une grande entreprise parce que ce n'est pas  t
comme j'ai une excellente technologie maintenant, ce que
vous pensez être bien, ils voient la grande
entreprise faire du dépistage et c'est la
technologie intéressante là-bas, ils ne
viennent pas vous dire que vous avez une
technologie de requête, venez ici, je vais l'appliquer
ici et je veux des problèmes  nous-mêmes non en
fait vous en tant qu'entreprise vous devez
apprendre vous-même où vous pouvez apporter cette
valeur et les gens parlent en effet de l'
innovation des arts et ensuite de l'innovation d'
autres personnes pensent aux
trucs techniques des publicités l'enfer ce n'est pas
chaque ID technique a été répété  pour
vous 10 à 20 fois il y a plus d'idées
qu'il n'y a de personnes sur cette planète les
vrais changeurs de jeu la vraie différence en
matière d'innovation c'est la réalisation du Yeti ce
n'est pas seulement à propos de la chose technique
que vous découvrez c'est aussi comment
dois-je l'utiliser comment devrais-je  vendre est
quelle est l'histoire derrière cela quelle est la
valeur comment quelqu'un peut-il l'appliquer dans
sa situation spécifique tout le monde est
habitué au monde qui l'entoure directement
et vous si  vous apportez une nouvelle
solution, un nouveau produit sur le marché, vous
devez vraiment pouvoir l'adapter pour l'
adapter au problème spécifique de vos
clients, c'était donc l'un des autres
problèmes de l'entreprise dans laquelle
nous sommes.  vendent des trucs aux entreprises mais si
vous parlez à un expert ou si vous lisez un
livre d'économie 99% de ce qu'il y a dedans
concerne la vente de l'ouverture du prochain
type de café apportant un nouveau bonbon
sur les marchés un nouveau réseau social donc
beaucoup  des informations que vous obtenez
concernent ce qu'est le codage et dans le jargon du
commerce au consommateur, ce qui est en fait
assez simple en tant que marché,
ce sont de petits budgets, les gens peuvent décider d'
accord aujourd'hui je cuisinerai je boirai du Coca
Cola demain boir du Pepsi et peut-être le
jour d'après  Je vais essayer certains dr.  poivre
donc ce sont des décisions petites et faciles à
prendre et vous pouvez facilement expérimenter
cela, mais mais l'entreprise dans laquelle nous étions
était l'entreprise, ce qui signifie
ok aujourd'hui je dois décider de quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros et il y a dix
personnes qui me regardent de  le dos et
dire est que ce gars prend la bonne
décision, donc les affaires des entreprises sont
totalement différentes des affaires des consommateurs,
il faut beaucoup plus de temps avant que les gens puissent
même décider, puis ils recommencent à
hésiter et les budgets sont
beaucoup plus gros, donc ce n'est pas si facile alors quoi
vous devez faire est de prendre la route en
fait vous avez votre grande pièce d'identité et
surprendre le prix que vous devriez en fait
si vous envisagez de démarrer notre entreprise, vous
devriez vraiment le premier jour où vous avez
ce plan écrire un morceau de papier
quel est le produit que je vais  vendre et je
vais le vendre le mettre dans un coffre et au bout de
trois ans ouvrir ce coffre et vous
commencerez à rire parce qu'il ne
ressemblera jamais et c'est une bonne chose
aussi parce que parce que  utiliser c'est ce qui
va vous démarquer c'est sous
son tu commences prêt et la chose que
vous devriez faire ensuite est simplement de prendre la
route et de commencer à tester votre identifiant commencez à
expérimenter allez aux clients potentiels en
expliquant ce que vous voulez leur apporter
comment ça  leur apportera de la valeur etc etc
obtenir un dialogue et en fait vous
apprendrez beaucoup d'eux certaines personnes
vous ignoreront et je dis que ce n'est pas pertinent d'
autres vous aideront et en tant que tel
vous pourrez façonner votre produit et
comme je l'ai dit avant  ce n'est pas seulement une
mise en forme technique, c'est une façon de l'
apporter, allez-vous l'apporter, puis vous leur vendez une
boîte ou veulent-ils la boîte et aussi
un manuel ou veulent-ils une boîte et vous vous tenez à côté et leur dites
comment  utiliser les blocs, cela peut sembler un peu
drôle, mais c'est ainsi que vous
devez comprendre quelle autre chose que j'ai
découverte ici comment devrait-elle être mise
sur le marché et la seule chose que vous pouvez
découvrir c'est en prenant la route
et puis tal  roi aux gens bien avant
de commencer à étudier la taille du marché et le temps
d'accès aux marchés et le changement de valeur,
etc.  ce dont j'ai besoin parce que c'est le
point que
vous devez obtenir vous devez trouver dans
le jargon le produit adapté au marché et
cela ne devrait pas coûter cher
bonne nuit vous montrer la diapositive des
experts et j'ai un peu parlé des
experts que nous avons beaucoup  d'experts
autour d'eux, beaucoup d'entre eux sont des hommes d'affaires qui
savent très bien comment fonctionne le monde de l'entreprise,
mais en fait, lorsque
vous parlez à des clients
et à d'autres entrepreneurs,
vous constaterez en fait que le meilleur conseil est celui que
vous obtenez gratuitement c'est  une
leçon que j'aimerais que vous reteniez à la maison des
relations construites parlez aux gens apprenez
comment les entreprises apprenaient à connaître une
certaine industrie fonctionnait et vous
obtiendrez beaucoup de conseils gratuitement  parce que les gens
sont heureux de partager leurs découvertes avec
vous quand les gens commencent à facturer de l'
argent pour l'expansion de votre plan d'affaires, c'est
juste de l'argent perdu, ne le faites pas euh et puis
ouais pour revenir au sujet d'aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est ouais quelle est la meilleure version de
vous-même je ne  Je ne crois pas au
concept d'une meilleure version, ce en quoi je
crois davantage est le concept d'une
version plus adaptée de moi-même parce que j'ai dit
ouais tu dois sortir et expérimenter
et en fait ouais peut-être que c'était ce que je
faisais  de même quand on est
chercheur la même chose après les
expériences et regardez le résultat de
vos expériences racontez votre histoire de A
à B et au prochain client vous êtes
toujours vous racontez votre histoire de Beit B à
B vous voyez comment ils ont réagi d'accord  ça
attire plus l'attention quand je le dis de
cette façon en fait la même chose que vous
ne changez pas tant que ça ici vous utilisez juste
les mêmes outils d'expérimentation dans un
contexte différent et aussi vous devez
être capable de rêver grand comme un petit gars
ici  donc il aspire à grandir et à
devenir quelque chose d'autre et en fait
c'est ce que vous devriez faire, vous devez
essayer parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont une bonne idée, beaucoup d'entre eux dans les
universités et autres
instituts de recherche et ils
trouvent que c'est la meilleure idée de tous les temps  et puis ils ont
passé cinq ans à réfléchir ou
quelqu'un devrait utiliser sa carte d'identité parce que c'est
fantastique, n'est-ce pas, cela changera le
monde, cela ne changera jamais le monde si
vous le laissez dans votre tête et ne l'utilisez
pas, donc mon message serait  si vous
avez une si bonne idée, sortez de votre
immeuble et essayez de la vendre, essayez
de la concrétiser, car ce n'est qu'alors que
vous rendrez le monde meilleur,
vous réaliserez quelque chose et vous
regarderez en arrière une partie  de votre vie et
soyez heureux qu'au moins vous essayez de
réaliser quelque chose avec cela, je voudrais
vous remercier